[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
fall guys is currently taking over the
world with its unique blend of battle
royale and
party play but ultimately there can be
only one
i've been playing since the early beta
days and have a few tactics and tricks
to help you win more games
please drop a like if any of this helps
you and leave any tips you have
in the comments below here's a bunch of
tricks tips and tactics
when playing four guys
[Music]
let's start with the whirly gig or the
whirly jig if you know your history
there are three main ways to improve
your game here the first
is right at the start of the course and
those pink
rotating obstacles at present what do
you do when you reach these
i presume you jump over them what if i
told you they could give you a speed
boost which could take you so far away
from the other players
to do this be sure to run around the
left side of the first circle
and don't jump you will be thrown
forwards the key to this
is to be hit at the very end of the
moving parts for maximum velocity
and don't worry about falling over the
edge there is an invisible barrier
keeping you in the game
zone after a little practice you'll be
head in every round
the next point of note is really a
beginner tip but you'll be surprised how
many people don't know how to climb the
ledge here
it's as simple as jumping and holding
grab which is
r2 on the ps4 i personally prefer the
quick double jump
but if those platforms are full try and
pull yourself up instead
there's one other super helpful tip on
the whirly gig in the final
area when you reach this section of the
course what do you do
do you go left right or central if you
choose to take on the propeller you'll
likely be thrown to the right hand side
of the course
which means most people you'll find are
on the right so if you want to avoid
everyone
simply take the left track and there
should only be a handful of people using
these platforms
but let's get real if you're a hardcore
player and you want to go all the way
and humiliate all the other players
you're gonna try your luck and get
through the propeller
here's the best tactic the best area of
attack
is this section here there's a small gap
where the propeller rotates which gives
us a slight advantage
in two ways firstly if we get hit at
this point
we have a slightly improved chance of
hitting the right pillar just here and
falling into the next zone but if you
don't want to leave that to chance
what you can do is jump and dive if you
die perfectly your body will go
under the propeller and you're in the
next section it's really that simple
and if for some reason you are hit there
is a huge chance you'll still make it to
the other side
check out this run to show you how
understanding a few of these skills
will see you win and qualify much
quicker than your competitors
[Music]
which game shall we look at next oh it's
a final level the fabulous fall mountain
in which we must grab the crown at the
top of the run
i've been playing this since the early
beta days and over that extra time i
think i have perfected a path
for you it's essentially a left side
push
let me break it down and tell you why
it's the right choice
first the left side is technically
shorter than the right
it's only by a few milliseconds but
still in speed tests it's quicker to go
central and then veer off to the left
and for some reason avoid this area it
can slow you down
and i have no idea why next here's the
reason we don't take the center route
it's the worst place to take balls to
the face don't get me wrong it's still a
winning strat
but through the middle your chances of
being hit are extremely high
when compared to other routes so for
this reason we are going left
the first part of the run is extremely
simple and in fact
the only issue you're going to find is
when you hit these mallets here
the safest route is to go to the left of
the mallets as you cannot be hit there
but this takes a few extra steps and
therefore people will start catching you
up
so for that reason we're going to go
straight through the middle of the two
here's the tactic due to the orientation
of the mallets they will actually propel
us forward if they hit us here
can you see that there's a strong chance
of this happening but it's not for
certain
next we are deliberately running to the
right of the final mallet
this is for the exact same reason extra
protection
if we run on the left it will hit us
away from the mountain top whereas by
running to the right hand side
if we are struck there's a strong chance
it will push us up the mountain which is
what we want
and then finally it's all on you to make
the jump and hold your nerve and hold on
for dear life
i have calculated that i have won 66 of
the finals i've played on fall mountain
so i think this is the best way to win
but i'm completely open to suggestions
is there a better route to the top route
route
route route so what's the next game
we're going to break down
slime climb it is so this is the only
real racing challenge game
due to the pink lava rising the tips and
tactics on this stage are both
at the foot of the climb and when
executed correctly
will get you far enough ahead of the
crowd to release the pressure
of potentially being stuck with the rest
of them and it's actually
super simple we can cut out the first
section of the course by simply bouncing
on this
triangular obstacle look how much we can
skip
and how far ahead we can be but let's
see the downside of this too
on some attempts this can be a cluster
truck
so many people will try this and um
i've fallen a few times i must admit so
knowing when to give up and just take
the course on naturally is imperative
lately i've been trying to find another
way out of this problem
and i simply wait watch this i simply
stand around
and wait for the mayhem to calm down
long enough for me to hit my jump
and go back into the leading party this
jump requires space and with more people
using this technique every day
waiting for your turn could be the right
thing to do another shortcut you can
think about using is on the very next
section
and is simply missing the final turn
here and jumping up at this point
hey i said some of these tips weren't
mind-blowing the little hacks are quite
important to giving you the edge
anyway here's both shortcuts back to
back to show you the lead of the main
group
you can muster i do think it's worth
practicing these shortcuts
what do you think next stage please
oh it's fall ball without a doubt my
favorite game in fall guys
and this is why headers so the biggest
tip of all is to
get good at heading the ball as they
spawn back
in the trick is to line yourself up with
the back of the shadow when the ball
spawns
and jump straight up in the air no need
to run forwards no need to dive anywhere
it's simple it's just a well-timed jump
it's possible and increasingly likely
you'll go up against someone who can
head up
just as well as you if not better and
these
are the scariest matches of all and the
best tip i have here is to cancel them
out holding them down it's terrible i
know but if they are better than you
take them out and hope the rest of your
team can play the game out without you
if you've got a friend though
coordination can change this game
completely
check out this example my friend spear
held the opposition's best player
and allowed me to head of the ball in
and yeah we turned the tide and we went
on to win that match
teamwork does make the dream work but
let's take this back a bit
if you're simply running after the
football all the time you are not
helping your team to your fullest
it's time to pick a position the two
most important positions in this game
are the goalkeeper
or maybe two goalkeepers if i'm honest
which doesn't get the respect it
deserves
and the other position is to stand on
the halfway line your job here is to
stop
any ball entering your half and helping
out in defense
when things go wrong you'll likely
actually be the main goal scorer too as
another one of your jobs is to hit the
ball
as it respawns but don't feel pressured
to score every time
getting the ball in the other team's
half is the best thing you can do
master these roles and you will never
lose another game of fall ball
next game mode please oh perfect match
well this one is completely down to your
memory skills
i do have one tip though you are three
times more likely to remember an image
if you see it
in the correct orientation that means if
you see it face on
so if you are stood sideways and looking
at the side screens you are less likely
to remember everything on the ground
so make your way to the back of the
course and look at the center screen
i don't know how this works but science
has proven that it does work
so take advantage of it and of course
one of the greatest tips when you forget
where everything is
run towards the biggest pile of people
and hopefully they were paying attention
and they got it right
and now you've got it right next stage
hexagon
the final round which triggers so many
people for this one i'll break down two
tactics
one for ultra aggressive players like me
and one for those who want to stay out
of danger and slowly but surely win the
game
let's go with the passive style first
this technique
again it's simple and involves breaking
the tiles as slowly
as possible jumping one tile at a time
carefully don't get me wrong i think
this is a key strat
but i personally don't like it as if you
mess up once in the late game
this can happen rip that's because
people are below you making holes below
you
personally i prefer to play ultra
aggressive my theory is simple i
pressure other people into making
mistakes
i run towards them like a game of
chicken and if they don't move i
deliberately cut off their path
wherever possible i only go defensive
when i have a clear advantage of height
or there are only limited tiles
remaining this won't guarantee you a win
but playing aggressively moves the game
forward quicker and shortens the weight
and you'll be surprised how many people
don't play well under pressure
oh in fact there is one more thing i see
people miss often
and it's simply looking at the layer
below them and knowing when there's a
right time to fall
i know this sounds backwards but if
you're following a line of tiles which
have nothing underneath
you're putting off the inevitable you're
going to drop into the pink stuff
so my advice is to be aggressive look up
where the best places to drop are
and switch to slow jumping to guarantee
the final win
good luck you're gonna need it our next
game mode please
block party another super simple game
which attempts to push us off a platform
and it's relatively easy to get an
advantage here right now where do you
stand when playing block party
is it in the middle is it near the back
i have a suggestion for you
the two main issues to be aware of in
this mode are the amount of players
around you which
impacts your movement and the second
point is how much time you have
to react to the blocks coming forward to
rectify both these issues
i currently stand here and look off the
edge of the platform
usually i'm quite secluded maybe there's
a couple more players here but the main
reason we're doing this is to get a view
over the pink lava to see the exact
moment the shapes rise up
by doing this we maximize the amount of
time we have to react
getting into the right position before
many players have even seen the shapes
they need to avoid
it may only be a second of time but that
second will make the game
far easier well until the last part
that remains a complete cluster truck
okay one more mini game let's do this
it's royal fumble another end game which
can frustrate players massively
usually the game mode sees five players
battling to hold on to one single tail
in the final second the tips for this
one aren't going to make you win every
game
but hopefully this will open your mind
to a tactical approach
first off if you start with the tail
hide this can be as simple as staying
still
the other players can waste up to one
minute of time finding you
and are actually attracted to movement
so staying still in the game if you
start with the tail
and all alone is actually a master
stroke and remember they can't tell you
have the tail
if your face on but when the shizzle
hits the fan and it definitely will
the biggest thing to note is this
chasing the person
is not a great idea i know that is
absolute madness isn't it but hear me
out
the runners and the chasers all run at
the exact same speed
which means if the person with the tail
is a skilled runner you will never
catch them by chasing them the best
thing you can do is learn the map
and figure out what most people do when
chased by doing this
when you have the tail you'll be able to
run to places safely and keep that tail
but most importantly the person with the
tail will actually bring you that tail
if you sit in ambush
and let the others do the chasing
thinking smart on royal fumble is the
difference between a lucky win
and a well-timed attack for victory so
there we have it eight mini-games in
fall guys broken down to give you the
edge
let me know your thoughts on this series
and if you'd like another episode
looking at different mini games
if you have any tips throw them below
i'll be sure to give you a heart
thanks for watching this i'm adam from
playstation grenade and i'll see you in
the final
thanks for watching see ya
[Music]
you